Society punishes men for not being
self-accountable but Society does not
punish women for not being
self-accountable give you an example if
you're a man and you're arrogant and you
think you're something when you're not
trust me Society will teach you very
quickly that you don't matter when you
don't get laid when you stay [ __ ]
broken if you're a chick and think
you're something when you're not you can
run around with your ego still get dates
still get laid still have a fairly
sensible social life society as a whole
doesn't come along and slap you in the
face with realizations if you're a man
and you think you're something you're
not it is a ticking Time Bomb until
Society teaches you a lesson that's the
difference this is why men in general
are more self-accountable because the
men who are not self-accountable get
[ __ ] up so those who are successful
are very self-accountable people they
look at themselves and go okay the only
way I'm going to get and progress
further the reason she left me the only
way I'm going to do better make more
money etc etc I have to change most
women don't want to do that they don't
sit and think I have to change they
think oh he left me because it's him and
I lost my job because my boss and this
is this because of this they not you
women don't look in the mirror and
change a [ __ ] thing